well hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba this is Ashley Edna you
might have seen her before here she's a
regular she's one of the regs as we like
to color you can follow her at Ashley
Edgar I don't ever go to your Instagram
yes actually Ashley Edna I'm just saying
that because I want you to think I'm
looking at your bikini photos
do you like my photos only your bikini
photos video with Greg in this girl I
don't make I'm gonna make jokes like
that people get so defensive for her as
they should but we're gonna watch the
trailer for pitch perfect 3 now I have
not seen pitch perfect uno or pitch
perfect dose but I have seen pitch
perfect 1 & 2 I just wanted to make that
punch line I have not seen pitch perfect
quarter to and you've seen pitch perfect
one uh-huh how did you see pitch perfect
2
no one's seen this second one John did a
reaction to the first trailer by himself
pretty much the pitch perked race I
watch a lot of Dora the Explorer yeah
the only way people know Spanish that
sure
[Music]
so we think tonight about this isn't it
we didn't invite you guys to sing we
invited you to watch excuse me
I just thought you guys were so busy
with your Aussie jobs and amazing lives
I am actually I was good timing will we
be going to second base we got three
beds
you guys just sing other people's songs
right like a cover band they turn into
NATO's hostess due to a resource
[Music]
they're really acapella
it's all over
[Music]
like to keep it
[Music]
[Music]
he's old brazen it I'm part of a group
too big opportunity for you [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
yay I haven't even seen any of them in
that trailer was making me laugh I gotta
watch the first two I am very good at
doing that like but when I am looking
forward to an installment of a film I am
very good at going I'm gonna watch the
previous ones before the next one comes
out and I really entertain that was
hilarious
he didn't seem to be enjoying it as much
as me no way that it looks funny it's
can I mean the first one was good I
liked it okay so I get it there's this a
cappella group who does acapella chicks
yeah are they all competition movies you
know what the first one came out a long
time ago I'm assuming it was the cast
looks like they're gonna be really fun
and funny and the writing seems like
it's good oh yeah the jokes were really
getting me ya know timing is great I
like movies with like a Samba love like
a bunch of funny woman but what's cool
is that they're more than funny they
actually seem like very talented
are they really singing that these
actors actually be a girl what's her
name Anna Kendrick she does see yeah
okay but I don't know about the other
ones that I know she sings yeah wonder
if that's all real if that's really them
you know doing the acapella but it looks
like it's got some action in there it's
got some singing there's everything
coming yeah I mean now they're gonna get
the male demographic with the explosions
and stuff yeah jumping off the boats I
have energy oh I was watching over your
shoulder hmm and I feel like they really
pared down that element because the
first trailer has a lot more action in
it yeah the point where most of us had
to go what is this
first should like the first trailer
release for this like you're putting in
action comedies it looked almost like 22
Jump Street I'm okay with it I think for
a group about acapella people competing
we need more action sequences yet more
of me in the seats and then the two
judges I always forget their names oh
they're they're funny Elizabeth Banks
yet and John Michael Higgins they're
funny and I like their little like thing
that they got going on in these movies
yeah oh dude no maybe I've seen the
trailers for the other one I like I have
no recollection looks like it has more
action for sure well the first one
didn't have just like it was just like a
singing competition the action stuff
seems like it's a bit it doesn't seem
like an action scene it seems like it's
gonna be used for funny purpose not like
wow that was really intense what went
down I feel like it's gonna be some
because I recently would like planes or
helicopters did it show that or my
interesting comment somehow is gonna
come in later mmm my thoughts I don't
know Wow and then the fan theory the
massive the meddling group the girl with
the short short hair she's really pretty
who is she I don't know but I want to
get to know her name Rubirosa lesbian
girl from Orange is the new black yeah
yeah and she is really pretty
yeah my biggest takeaway from this video
is John should have been in this video
it's perfect I'm the only one who shared
it really should just be it looks like
they're wrapping it up trilogy then they
need to do spin-offs and create a
pitch-perfect cinematic universe that's
what they're pitching it has ha pitch
fit it adds these pitches this pitch
miss comes out five days after your
pitched a does it yeah
guys are you excited to get your singing
on YouTube questions they subscribe to
the real rejects notification bells
exist click them anyway they might not
do anything Ashley has a YouTube channel
called when life hands you more how-to
with Ashley and Morgan that your social
media how is how to's with Morgan and
Ashley - blonde girl say Morgan Ashley
also made it Instagram so are you - how
to's with Ashley Morgan no more
confusing is it there you go people